[Music]
as announced well over a month ago
the hearts on fire audiobook has
recently been released
these next couple of videos will be my
take on this story but much like the
novels i've covered in the past i'll
barely be scratching the surface as far
as the detail and the full immersion
that the audiobook provides
if you are at all interested in the
division story of which i assume you
would be if you're watching my channel i
strongly urge you to check it out on
audible they've done an amazing job
hearts on fire is set in a time before
the existing game franchise
a prequel to the division one the story
follows a new recruit called hoskins
we'll be following hoskin's journey as
she is recruited and brought into the
ranks of the shd
all while maintaining her day job as a
firefighter and a paramedic
in new york city until one day a
biological attack strikes down the city
sending it to the brink of collapse
hoskins along with their training
partner and fellow agent
are tasked with following the path of a
growing hostile presence
calling themselves the cleanest
melanie hoskins is a firefighter
paramedic she has been called to a case
where a young boy has fallen from a tree
yet in a shaky situation hoskins is able
to calmly tend to his injuries
and bring him back to a stable condition
while packing up and preparing herself
for the next emergency call
she's approached by a man in a suit he
compliments her on the excellent job she
did while attending to the boy
and comments on how cool she kept
herself during the situation and then
proceeds to offer her his business card
he tells her that he is part of another
agency and that he has potentially a
unique job opportunity for her
hoskins thanks the man but explains that
she needs to head off to her next call
out as the job has just been dispatched
through the radio
on route with a co-worker to the next
call out she takes a closer look at the
card
she can tell that the man she spoke with
is from a government agency
uninterested in whatever he or his
agency has to offer she puts his card
aside
and carries on with her day
one morning when arriving at the station
to begin her shift her chief calls her
into the office
she has been flagged for routine
mandatory hr harassment training
it has been held downtown she
reluctantly makes her way there
hoskins eventually arrives at an
unmarked building and signs in at the
front desk
the lady behind the counter starts off
by giving her a number of forms to fill
out
non-disclosure agreements homeland
security forms
but before she can query this further
and while asking if she's in the right
place
a man appears from out of one of the
back rooms it was the man from the other
day
the one who'd given her the card but
what was he doing here
as it turns out this whole hr training
is just a cover that he's set up
so that she is available to talk to him
about this job opportunity
frustrated by his deception she storms
out of the building
he quickly follows her and tries to
explain that this is much bigger than
him
or her and that the president of the
united states needs her help
startled by this she laughs but he
assures her
that this is very much real he is a part
of an agency that is there to prepare
for the very worst
when all other means have failed that
they are the last line of defense
he finally introduces himself as jason
shu and goes on to explain that in order
for her to know any more than this
that she needs to sign the ndas and then
complete the screening process through
to a certain level before he is able to
provide any more detail on what this is
all about
hoskins eventually agrees to go back
inside with them and make a start on the
process
first up there are the psychometric
tests where her aptitude
personality and skills would be tested
through a number of various scenarios
she successfully completes the step shu
congratulates her
however he does inform her that this is
just the beginning and that she has at
least a years worth of training and
testing ahead of her before she will
or won't be fully successful in the
recruitment process
shu told her that the agency would be
handling all the details in regards to
booking out time in her calendar
and providing adequate cover stories for
a time away from work
and her family he stressed to her that
no one
under any circumstances was to know what
she was doing including her husband
and child
over the next 12 months hoskins has put
through a number of rigorous and intense
courses and training
in a variety of different scenarios
including firearms
close quarters combat equipment like
body armor and shd tech
hostage situations resilience judgment
instincts mental stability and the
ability to make calls that could save
or cost lives during this time she meets
up with another potential agent in
training
anderson and on the last day both were
given confirmation via their watches
that they were successful shu approaches
the two new agents
and informs them that they are now a
part of his cell
now fully fledged division agents they
will remain inactive until they receive
the call
for now hoskins is to go back to her
normal life and apart from training
exercises that they will complete over
time
in order to help keep them sharp she
will be stepping away from this life
perhaps forever providing that there
aren't any catastrophic events anytime
soon
however four months later the worst
happens
it's black friday and even the terrible
weather isn't holding back the thousands
of eager shoppers
it isn't too long before people start to
get sick and reports start to come in
about a new strange illness
striking down seemingly healthy people
as a paramedic hoskins is in the thick
of it and has to work day and night due
to the sheer scale
and spread of this mysterious illness
isolated from her family yet in the same
house and unable to hug her son
she is doing everything that she can to
keep them safe
her job demands a sacrifice and she
accepts it but it doesn't make it any
easier
suddenly and on a day seemingly like
every other she's been living lately
after a particularly long shift her
husband notices her watch starting to
glow
the severity of this unknown virus has
started taking a drastic toll on the
people of new york
and it seems that now the time has come
where she has been activated and called
into action
hoskin feels like for a second there
that her heart has stopped
is it time had things finally gotten so
bad that the local authorities can no
longer handle this on their own
clearly confused her husband watches
anxiously as she grabs a go bag that she
had hidden away
and starts to gear up scantic lenses
earpiece body armor getting more and
more agitated and alarmed
he tries to question her what is she
doing why does she have a gun
and where is she going unable to tell
him exactly what she's doing or who she
works for
hoskins explains that he and their child
need to leave the city as soon as
possible
and that she won't be coming with them
that this is something she needs to do
and while he may not understand this and
he needs to know that she's been
training for an event like this
for some time before leaving the house
to meet at the rendezvous point with the
rest of her cell
she has to make a phone call although
it's against the rules
she feels she has to tell her sister to
get as far away from the city as
possible
hoskins and her sister haven't been
close for years but regardless she can't
just leave her here
unknowing and oblivious to the fact that
something big is about to occur
unfortunately johanna is simply
convinced that all of this
is just something made up by the
government to control the population and
that there is no way she's conforming
or going anywhere hoskins tries to
convince her otherwise
and begs her to listen to reason but
unfortunately she has to abandon the
call
as her cell is yelling into her earpiece
asking her why she hasn't left yet
anderson and hoskins find themselves
looking after a sarah hospital in lower
manhattan
the medical staff are overwhelmed and
with the sick queuing up down the street
people are scared and understandably
starting to panic
it doesn't take long before things begin
to get out of control
and suddenly and without warning the jtf
guards
leave and all hell breaks loose
hoskins and anderson sensed the
situation quickly getting out of control
as they notice weapons starting to
appear within the crowd
they don't want to abandon their post
but with the jtf now gone
they are only moments away from being
completely overwhelmed and they no
longer have a choice
they gather the medical personnel and
escape the compound
but before they're able to make it very
far there is a loud bang and a blinding
burst of light
anderson quickly drags hoskins to the
side and out of harm's way
they know they need to get as far away
as possible from here yet before they
can leave
anderson stresses he needs to do
something and he needs her help
his family is nearby and they are being
held in quarantine under jtf guard
while this request is completely off
mission hoskins eventually agrees to
help him
however when they arrive the jtf are
nowhere to be seen
panicking anderson makes his way to
where his family is staying
but there is no one around and the only
thing that can be found
is scorch marks anderson's family has
been killed
unable to hold back his emotions
anderson is beside himself
hoskins tries to calm him down but
outside on the street is a group of
people
they're wearing gas masks carrying axes
flamethrowers and other weapons
attempting to grab his attention and run
her attempts are futile
as anderson is consumed by grief she
stands back helplessly and in shock
as he plows headfirst into the crowd to
have his vengeance on the people who
killed his family
life science disrupted
mortified by what she's just witnessed
but with no time to actually process it
for the group has now turned their
attention to her she runs wildly towards
quarantine wall
the hostiles are chasing her closely
behind
she makes it to the wall and frantically
climbs to the top but they have caught
up
and immediately opened fire on her a
bullet finds its target
and hits her directly in the stomach
suddenly
and without warning one of them drops to
the ground and the others soon start to
scramble for cover
another agent has appeared at the scene
and is returning fire
seeing she is injured he immediately
radios for medical support
the agent that has saved her life is
jason shu
before taking her back to base camp he
identifies to her that the hostiles that
we're chasing are known as
the cleanest and that they have been
popping up all over the city
and on top of this a large number of the
activated agents are missing
and it appears that this is only just
the beginning
flying in via helicopter captain
xander's and his unit of lmb
land on the roof of the district union
bank headquarters
meeting them is a representative of the
bank
sanders gets straight to work assigning
tasks to his team
they are just one of many of the last
man battalion units that have been
deployed inside the city
and it's their job to secure the digital
assets held on site
taking his intel officer with him they
head down to the basement to check out
what they're working with
as new york is a central hub for all of
the bank's information
it's too large and sensitive to be
transferred remotely
the lmb has been employed to decrypt and
back up this information
this process could take up to 13 days
and all while the chaos continues to
unfold
outside on the streets of manhattan
five days later and things outside the
building continue to get worse
xander's soldiers have their work cut
out for them holding off a number of
looters and growing hostile groups from
entering the building
the bank rep is starting to freak out he
is obviously out of his depth
and frustrated with how long he thinks
things are taking
zanders and his team are showing their
experience with their calm and patient
exterior
to the situation at hand suddenly
the power goes out and with no power the
server's backup has halted
zanders considers his options with no
power they can't do their job
and it's only a matter of time until
their location has the potential to get
overwhelmed
as men report to him that there is a
group starting fires just down the
street from them
and that this is most likely what caused
the power to cut off to the block
sanders quickly heads outside deciding
to have a look at the fast approaching
fires for himself
he decides to respond to the threat and
takes a squad of his men
they begin moving cautiously towards the
firestarters and he prepares his men to
be ready to engage
two of the unknown persons begin making
their way towards sanders and his men
and the one seemingly to be in charge
johanna fisher
shouts out demanding to know who they
are sanders responds
as it turns out they know each other
zanders and fisher had once served
alongside each other in the military
each calling off their troops they
agreed to reconvene
inside the bank it has been a decade
since they served together
and they have a lot to catch up on all
the while the bank representative is
complaining
however zanders soon puts him in his
place he explains that the pmc he works
for has been employed by the bank to
secure some assets
but their burning of buildings on the
street has put a halt on their work
they need the power to be returned
fisher and her people are locals from
around this area of manhattan
they have worked sanitation on these
streets before the virus outbreak
and they have exceptional local
knowledge on the area so they agree to
guide them to the power grid
in exchange for some weapons
[Music]
fischer's people take two of zander's
men through the sewers to a compound
that should be able to give them access
to the substation grid
while she remains behind so that they
can catch up on what's been happening in
each other's lives
while waiting on the return of their men
fisher and xander's reminisce on what
they've been up to
zanders talks about how he joined the
private military company after his time
in the military ended
how it's what he knows best and that it
pays a damn site better than anything
else he could be doing
fisher explains that she's done taking
orders and that she is still struggling
to get back into normal life
but isn't willing to go back to military
life
she discusses joe ferro their leader and
how he's brought everyone together
and is giving everyone a purpose and a
logical way to fix the situation
with fire they will rid the city of the
virus
eventually the lights turned back on
their men were successful in securing
power back to the building
after they returned fischer and her
cleaners go back on their way
however before she leaves xander's hands
over one of his lmp radios
so that they can keep in contact and he
can let them know when their weapons
arrive
[Music]
assistance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay